komm mit mir auf einen Business Class
Flug von Mexico nach Frankfurt schon
beim Einsteigen wuren wir mit einem Glas
Schaumwein und einem Cocktail begrüßt
den wir uns erstmal gegönnt haben es
fällt sofort der Sitz auf man hat
unfassbar viel Platz und ganz viele
verschiedene Einstellungsmöglichkeiten
also haben wir es uns gemütlich gemacht
und einen ersten Blick ins Menü geworfen
und das kann sich wirklich sehen lassen
dann haben wir auch schon die Vorspeise
bekommen weiter ging es mit einer
leckeren Hauptspeise die Optik ist ein
bisschen ausbaufähig und danach gab es
auch ein Dessert also drei Gänge mitten
in der Luft und dann kommen wir auch
schon zum wahrscheinlich größten Luxus
zum Schlafen ich habe meinen Sitz in
einer hor zontale Schlafposition
gebracht die Augen zugemacht und wie ein
Baby mitten in der Luft geschlafen am
nächsten morgen bin ich aufgewacht zu
einem wunderschönen Frühstück es gab
Marmeladen Säfte Kaffee also wirklich
alles was zum guten Frühstück gehört und
es ist einfach schön muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen es macht einfach Spaß das
in der Luft zu genießen dass all das in
ein Flugzeug möglich ist ist wirklich
unglaublich und ich bin sehr froh dass
ich diese Reise erleben durfte und dann
sind wir auch schon wieder gelandet